well who do you want to be well if you
want to be something different then
write a script who am I and then
practice it and practice makes habit and
if you practice something and it becomes
habitual then there's a point where you
don't have to practice anymore just like
driving a car you don't have to practice
put the key and think about wherever the
hell you want you're off on the road
without even thinking about the details
fake it till you make it you're not a
happy person and your life is unhappy
unhappy I said but you want to be a
happy person then I said then here's
what you do all day long as many times
as you can remember you say yourself I
am happy I am happy you could be
miserable I don't really care you just
have to say to yourself I am happy I am
happy and then there's a day where you
wake up and you don't have to say it
anymore why you made a program by
habituation you'll wake up happy and
you'll be happy and that's called fake
it till you make it I love it but that's
the same idea hi I'm Bruce Lipton author
of the bestselling books the biology
belief spontaneous Evolution and the
honeymoon effect I'm here to thank Evan
carmichel for featuring me on his
YouTube channel and and I want to let
you know that Evan is giving away links
where you can watch the First episodes
of my special guia series entitled inner
Revolution for free Evan is making this
offer to thank you for watching this
video you will find the links in the
description section below thank you hey
it's EV car Michael and I watch these
videos every day because I need them for
motivation being around successful
entrepreneurs every morning helps me
believe that I can do great things too
it's like your morning coffee but for
your goals kickstarting your day with a
blast of positivity so here is a
challenge for you try watching One video
every morning for the next 30 days and
let's find out together if they help you
do great things too if you're in leave a
# believe in the comments below so I can
celebrate with
you so today let's learn the seven steps
to recreate yourself enjoy St number two
is set clear goals with Arnold
Schwarzenegger I felt many
times that I'm not a dis iined
person but people always insist and say
oh it must take so much discipline every
day to get up and every day you went in
a gym at 7:00 in the morning and you
worked at the 9:30 in the morning and
then you went to college after that and
then you went this and this and you
worked in construction I was like
looking forward to getting up in the
morning and looking forward driving to
the gym and working out 2 and a half
hours and then going down to the beach
and taking a r in a deep sand and uh
getting some cardio work done in order
of I say I was looking forward to it it
was not like oh my God I have to do
another workout yes you do that when for
instance sometimes people go to the gym
and the doctor says you know you should
go to the gym and you should work out
because otherwise you know I see some
problems coming up high cholesterol and
body fat and this and that and you're
going to go and wipe out you know 10
years younger than you want
to if there's ever the right time to
wipe out yeah but I mean in any case so
that person you can see in the gym is
there and they just they do their reps
and they do their sets and they're not
really into it you can see there's no
life in the eyes you know what I'm
saying where it's like they really they
grabed the weight and they do those sets
and they get the pump and they feel good
and they put the weights down and get
the next heavy weight and they do the
set and so that's really fun but that
person is kind of like a vegetable in a
way they just cruise around in the gym
they sit on the light cycl and they just
pedal away and when you say to them
sister why do you work out they have no
answer then eventually they say well to
be honest with you the doctor told me
that I should get in shape that's better
for my health to bring my blood pressure
down and my cholesterol down and my body
fat down and all so they're not really
so I say to them always I said you know
what you should do is you should just
pick a goal that you can
chase they would say like what I say
what how much do you weigh mhm I'm
weighing 190 lb and I want to I want to
lower my body fat body weight I said
well why don't you pick a goal like you
want to go down to
170 and it it is now
March and by
August when you go to the beach you're
going to have a Slimmer waste less body
fat and you look leaner and you can be
proud of your
body as it pick that go oh that's a good
idea I say write it down and then write
down the sets you have to do to get you
there and the amount of reps you have to
do and the amount of life cycle that you
have to run and regular bicycle and
running that you have to do right all of
this down and then you mark it off every
day you mark it off that's what I did to
me that was really the that feedback
that I see a line being crossed that
means one was set was done it was a
satisfying kind of a thing the line was
crossed off the next line was crossed
off and so I tell people that and then
they just say oh my God this is yeah I'm
going to do that that is such a great
idea then they come back to me like a
few months later and they said this
worked it was unbelievable it worked it
was fantastic and it really gave me a
purpose you see so that's what it's it's
why it's so important they have a
purpose when you do things they have a
Clear Vision when you do things because
then you don't have to look at it kind
of like I have to be really disciplined
to do that or I have to make certain
sacrifices to do that because then it
just drags you in dead direction and you
just do the work step number three is
run strong systems with Robin charma run
strong systems you want to systematize
your life
systematize your travel systematize your
day you want to systematize your
business uh some some organizations like
Starbucks or McDonald's they have
systems and that ensures consistency and
so when you see yourself let's say
having a great day ask yourself or
deconstructed in your journal what did I
do today that made it so great that'll
bring great clarity and then build
systems around it if you have a team
builds systems maybe it's the morning
huddle maybe it's the once a week
lunchtime growth seminar I don't know
what it is but systems are so important
when I travel I have systems I call them
Sops standard operating procedures at
the office and with the team I have
systems at home I have systems so I
don't have to think and that frees a
bandwidth and willpower step number four
is leave your comfort zone with David
Goggins would you say you've built this
almost like sadistic quality where you
almost enjoy the pain I don't enjoy it
it's necessary yeah it's necessary so
every morning I wake up it's not just
about working out but for me working out
has been a very big part of my mental
growth so for me if I am not challenging
myself every day and I swear to God
people will not believe it I was over
almost 300 lbs twice in my life a person
that does that twice in his life does
not enjoy cardiovascular activity okay
yeah so people can put anything they
want to in their head I did realize one
thing the things I don't enjoy that I
still do that's where growth is at and
that's for me the only place growth is
at is in that very uncomfortable you
know in that uncomfortable Zone yeah so
I have to visit it every single day step
number five is connect with your
yourself with Mel Robins if you have big
goals you better stand in front of that
mirror and high five yourself every day
every single step of the way stop
looking around and waiting for everybody
else to do it start giving it to
yourself and you will be shocked at how
much more
quickly things start to happen at how
much more joy you experience along the
way at how much more present you are
yeah it's wild and this isn't about like
pumping yourself up to think you're like
the best person on the planet this is
like the
Baseline this is literally being like
you know what you're going to have an
okay day let's go do this you know what
I see you I know this is hard keep going
I I know you're nervous to have this
hard conversation with this person I
believe you can do it yeah let's go yeah
like it's just one little boost along
the way you know if you think about the
things that go
viral it's little kids in front of a
mirror with their parents getting them
to talk themselves
correct we all know that's how we're
supposed to feel mhm but we feel weird
and cheesy practicing it you kidding me
right the other thing that goes viral
all these teachers that are high-fiving
and fist bumping kids with this
handshakes as they go in and the mirror
one with the I am that just kind of went
viral why do we all love that because we
know each one of those kids just felt
seen and felt good and felt motivated
walking into that classroom mhm start
your day that way set number six is
develop a growth mindset with Andrew
hberman a fixed mindset versus a growth
mindset you know a fixed mindset is one
in which you're trying to look smart
that you're not so focused on effort
that your response to setbacks is to
give up you know and your academic and
other forms of performance tends to be
low whereas in a growth mindset your
goal tends to be to learn you tend to
Value effort more you tend to respond to
setbacks by working harder and your
performance is higher and I'm not trying
to make light of these lists these lists
are important because they help us
organize our information and
differentiate between a fixed versus
growth mindset but they don't tell us
why focusing on effort and engaging more
effort would actually translate into
higher performance for instance you
could imagine a scenario where the exact
opposite is true right we could make up
a justo story where if your identity is
so rigidly fixed to high performance
you're likely to outwork everybody right
that seems like a logical conclusion as
well but that's not the way it plays out
it's when your identity is attached to
your sense of ability to engage in
ongoing effort especially when you
receive signals that you're getting
things wrong or not performing well that
is tied to elevated performance and the
study using erps tells us that's likely
to be the case because of how people who
have a growth mindset Focus their
attention when they're told nope you got
that wrong or when people think they got
something right right they give an
answer and they say what's your
confidence level and they say 90% maybe
99% maybe even 100% they say it's wrong
people who have a fixed mindset focus on
the emotional response to that more of
their brain resources are devoted to ah
I got it wrong I thought I got it right
then the people who have a growth
mindset who are thinking wait okay then
what was that answer and how could I
possibly get that answer wrong I'm going
to figure that out okay now as you're
hearing this you're probably thinking oh
no I'm somebody who reflexively gets
disappointed when I get something wrong
well fortunately this is not just about
that 100 milliseconds to 5 seconds after
you're told something is wrong you can
shift from a fixed mindset to a growth
mindset response in fact that's an
important tool that we all need to learn
how to implement we all suffer from
fixed mindset all suffer from fixed
mindset in certain Endeavors and when we
get things wrong especially when there's
some embarrassment or shame which often
accompanies when we think we were very
right we're convinced we're right that
fixed mindset can really hijack our
emotional response but there are a lot
of data that point to the fact that at
those moments if we think okay I'm going
to step back from that and I'm going to
just think about the error I'm going to
think about what led to the error and
I'm going to start devoting my
intentional resources to that process
that process itself can be built up over
time such that we start to outweigh the
fixed mindset with growth mindset simply
by devoting our attentional resources to
the error acknowledging it happened
maybe feeling something something about
it maybe not it's really hard to control
our feelings what we can control as I
mentioned before is our effort and our
attention so focusing our attention on
why we got something wrong and really
digging into that that's growth mindset
in action so you'll notice as we have
this discussion about the more
mechanistic underpinnings of growth
mindset is that we're not talking about
psychological terms as much we're not
talking about ego protection we're not
talking about identity now all those
things are extremely important but the
problem with things like ego protection
and identity is that when we are faced
with results that we don't want and we
are faced with those results in a real
world context like we're not getting the
results we want in school in work in
athletics in relationships Etc we hear
these messages and we try to for
instance you know set our ego aside or
you know not attach our identity so much
to what is happening but it's really
really hard and it's really really hard
because statements like set your ego
aside or don't attach yourself to it so
much are wonderful aspirations but
there's no actual process that one can
go through by oneself that allows you to
immediately disentangle yourself from
your ego so when you're faced with
results that you don't like you can't
simply step back nor should you expect
yourself to be able to step back and say
oh I'm I'm not going to get upset about
this error right it makes perfect sense
why you would get upset about not
getting the results that you want
however once you start to understand
some of the mechanistic underpinnings of
what will allow you to rescue your
performance that is to start focusing on
those errors from a more cognitive and a
slightly less emotional stance or even a
combination of emotional and cognitive
right because it's very hard to suppress
our emotional response to something but
oftentimes we can enhance our
attentional or cognitive response to
Something in parallel with that and in
doing so we can kind of Rob some of the
emotional response and when we do that
sort of thing it's hard and anytime we
do hard things we generally want to know
that the doing of those hard things is
working that it's in service to
something and step number seven the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is acquire new skills with Alex heroi
the skills we learn through education
education comes from repeatedly doing
things and learning from that experience
the information that we acquire to learn
things comes in a lot of different forms
now the things that I actually invested
in workshops books seminars coaching
programs one-1 tutor one one mentorships
and Google and I would say if I had to
allocate a amount of time spent learning
things Google was still by far the
biggest one it's funny the other day I
just set up this new widget for our site
I Googled it and I did it in 2 hours and
so I think that the amount of time that
elapses between wanting to figure
something out and doing something the
more advanced you get shortens I
remember it took me 3 years to figure
out how to build a landing page and the
day I decided to do it it took me 4
hours so it took me 3 years and then 4
hours to actually figure it out because
I was avoiding ing the feeling of
sucking and so if you can confront
sucking faster and just get over that
idea that sucking is a bad thing then I
think you com press the time between you
and the skills you want the highest
value I've gotten from is from oneon-one
mentorship is from people who are far
ahead of me that were willing to speak
strategically into my life and that's
usually CU those people can identify all
three of those things they can identify
skill deficiencies they can identify
character trait deficiencies and they
can identify things that you believe
that are true that aren't so that is
where I've gotten the most leverage in
my life is on and I've paid 20 $30,000
an hour to many many different people
just to have them speak into my life
right underneath of that as I was coming
up was joining masterminds it was the
getting around other people because for
me it was very lonely and so just being
around other people doing things it a
got my competitive drive up cuz I always
wanted to be the best and seeing people
that I didn't think were like better
than me do something better than me gave
me hope that I too could do it I'd see
somebody be like I don't think they were
harder than me I don't think they've got
like some genius brain if they can do it
I can do it too also when I was in those
communities they would also already have
sifted through information for me cuz
there's lots of information out there
the problem is that we have limited time
so it's no longer about oh information's
free you can find anywhere it's not free
it costs time to go find where it is and
so the idea is when you pay someone for
information it's not you're paying for
the info you're paying for the time took
them to sort through it to hand it for
you so you're cutting time that's what
you're saving when you exchange the
money that's the idea and I think a lot
of people don't get that this is the
actual order that I bought things so the
first thing that I did I did free
interviews so I tried to reach out to
people so I just said hey I'll show you
the stuff that I've got you want to
share notes with me I can drive out
there we can meet up and that's how I
learned a lot of my initial stuff
usually it was older guys who were
willing to like you know take a young
young buck under under their wing if
you're young the advantage you have is
that you're young you can get a little
bit of that Goodwill from older guys
that you might not normally get if
they're the same age people like well
the millionaire won't let me pick his
brain it's like well no his time's more
valuable than yours either pay them or
you have to go down a run you have to
keep going down until there's somebody
that's either a peer or just slightly
ahead of you who you can provide value
to in a very narrow way the next one I
did is I I joined a mastermind that was
$10,000 and that was Sam backyard's
Mastermind rest in peace and he actually
took enough of a liking to me that he
said why don't you just become my
apprentice and then he started paying me
so it's kind of weird so I paid him and
then he paid me back so work from 4:00
a.m. to 4:00 p.m. every day with him
basically as his secretary and I learned
a ton 3 months just like learning all
these new terms sales copyrighting
affiliate marketing I learned all the
stuff just from him cuz he was in that
world from there I started my first gym
and I stayed in that gym Mastermind
during the time I also bought a weekend
workshop for uh Facebook ads I learned
Facebook ads in a small group of 10
people in 2 days it was really valuable
for me then I didn't really do anything
for a couple years and then I went to
traffic and conversion Summit so that
was an event and I just learned more
about Marketing in general I got
introduced to different softwares that I
then started using and then from there I
kind of got more into the digital
marketing world so I joined some
masterminds in that world I didn't do
coaching programs myself I actually
ended up buying them for teammates I
think the coaching programs are really
effective to teach methods so if there's
a method of acquisition you want to
learn whether it's like YouTube ads or
Twitter ads or cold calling whatever it
is joining a coaching program by other
people trying to learn the same thing
from some who's good is a great way to
FastTrack your success it just gives you
the accountability it helps you resolve
problems faster what you're buying is
speed it's not that you can't do it on
your own it's that you can do it faster
with help if you're trying to solve a
specific problem finding specific spefic
coaching programs is really good if
you've been stuck for a long time I
think that's where like masterminds and
101 mentorship is more valuable because
you probably have a strategic issue more
than a tactical
problem every news Outlet is just
reporting on problem so if you're
looking for problems just just go to any
major mainstream publication just see
problems problems problem and what most
people do is they they see the problems
and they panic and they get scared and
they and they hide and they go inside
and they get protective and they go
scarcity mindset and and they just are
fearful and so the media uses this as
opportunities to inject more fear
because you have to keep reading about
what the thing is because now I'm scared
for my life where the entrepreneurs and
and I I see that as an opportunity like
these are all opportunities anytime
there's there is pain and frustration
there's opportunities every great
business has been started by an
entrepreneur who saw a giant problem and
instead of complaining said huh maybe I
can fix that and they built the business
on top of it so I think there's a
there's a lot of negativity in the
system there's a ton of problems uh
which means there's a ton of
opportunities I as much as people
complain about all the problems that
we're having now I think it's the
greatest time to be alive like I think
it's never been easier to be an
entrepreneur and win the opportunities
available to you today at 39 compared to
your parents when they were 39 Oh it's
it's a completely different world yeah
and so like you can actually go and do
whatever you want you can actually go
and build a business where when your
parents were 39 or my parents were 43
you had to be crazy to be an
entrepreneur you had to basically be
unemployable it's like you can't get a
job so your last resort is to start your
own business or you're just crazy where
now it's it's completely possible let's
just say that lack is ingrained in there
you got the story you lived on the
streets you lost everything you got
betrayed your business partner took
everything took your wife took you got
the story in the half okay okay you got
to start telling a new story of the
future right you got to believe in that
future more than you have to believe in
the past so how do you do that you only
believe in the past when you feel the
emotions of the past the only time
you're going to believe in the future is
when you feel the emotions in the future
right okay so in order for us to change
a belief or perception about our s and
our
lives we have to make a decision with
such firm
intention that the amplitude of that
decision carries a level of energy
that's greater than the hardware
programs in your brain and the emotional
conditioning in your body and your body
literally has to respond to your mind
that the choice that you're making to
change in that moment becomes a moment
in time that you never forget and here's
the key physically physically the
stronger the emotion you feel when you
make that choice the more you'll
remember the decision okay so then how
do we downregulate that old belief if
the trauma created emotional quo of six
or seven then your decision to change
your belief's got to be a nine right and
you got to come out of your resting
state and that moment has to Define you
you could say I know exactly where I was
the time and day it was who I was with
when I made my mind up to change right
cuz you created a long-term memory
long-term memories are created from
strong emotion right but the amplitude
of that emotion is greater than the
Betrayal Boom the body starts responding
to the mind and you're actually giving
your body a taste of the future
emotionally so you brand your impossible
no your body is actually getting the
taste of that future vent it's
experiencing the future now exact big
explosion on the quantum field big
explosion so the side effect of that is
if you combine that clear intention with
that elevated emotion you're basically
remembering your future and it looks no
different than remembering your past
think neurologically within the circuits
of that meory memory and feel within the
emotions of that new belief and watch
your life begin to change because
nothing changes in our life that we
change and when we change our energy we
change our life so now the experiment
all of a sudden is no longer based on it
being hard or trying or wishing or
wanting or hoping that's what we do when
we're lack we in lack or separation it's
about change so then when we finally
realize in order for
us to become abundant we have to
overcome the old personality and that's
95% of who we are right yes so then the
side effect of the beginning of this
process is a lot of discomfort it is a
lot of discomfort because you're
stepping outside the known into the
unknown and now you can't predict scary
no no you ra you'd rather hold on to
your lack pain suffering rather tell the
story of that at least makes you feel
something that's familiar when you step
outside and you're saying I'm not going
to complain about money any longer I'm
not going to complain about I don't have
any I'm not going to judge other people
who do I'm not going to say I can I'm
not worthy it's never going to work all
those things got to go I'm not going to
feel lack I'm not going to feel unworthy
I'm not going to feel separation I'm not
going to feel resentment these are the
things that are keeping my reality the
same now it's no longer about abundance
about who you become mhm so the
overcoming process becomes the becoming
process and so many people come to this
work they want abundance they want
healing they want a new relationship
they want a new career they want the
mystical but really they want wholeness
and and they want healing they want
peace they wholeness cuz they feel onho
well well when you're in lack or you're
in separation you're not whole imagine
feeling so much wholeness that's
impossible to want that's what our
that's what we're working on with people
then you can really enjoy a sunset then
you can really enjoy a meal then you can
really enjoy your friends then you can I
I I I talk to people that are very
abundant I mean I mean in the billions
abundant and you know so many of them
say we are in
misery we're in agony because they can't
enjoy life anymore that's what they want
I mean people want abundance to be able
to enjoy life they want to be able to do
whatever they want with whoever they
want as many times as they want wherever
they want that's Freedom right we want
abundance the sponsoring thought is
really they want freedom right or
whatever the sponsoring thought would be
right one of the things that will help
you to do the work to create the things
that you want in your life is it will
help you if you train your mind to start
spotting evidence as you're doing the
work as you're going through your day it
will help you if you train your mind to
start scanning the world and spotting
evidence that yes indeed the world is
sending you positive signals that things
are going to work out now why is it
important to to train your mind to help
you get what you want well the reason
why is because if you get into a
negative mindset if you start
thinking this business is never going to
work why even bother or I'm never going
to meet anybody it's nothing but losers
out there look at all these idiots on
hinge why the hell should I keep doing
this if you allow your mind to start to
rest in a pessimistic negative
protective scared and doubtful stance
your mind will continue to show you
reasons why there's nobody on hinge
worth talking to your mind will continue
to show you all the reasons why you will
never make it in business your mind will
continue to show you all the reasons why
you're never going to lose that weight
and be able to tuck in your shirt as my
friend Karin Crabtree always talks about
that transformational moment and when
your mind goes negative your mind starts
to scan the world and will show you more
reasons to stop and the power of
training your mind to spot positive
signs is very simple the power is that
your mind will start to show you reasons
to keep going your mind will help you
take the step your mind will encourage
you to feel optimistic to feel empowered
just like you woke up today on a Tuesday
and it was February 22nd 2022 and those
numbers are and up and that makes you in
your heart and soul go whoa something
cool could happen today like that only
happens like once in my lifetime those
numbers are going to line up like that
today is a really cool day let's go do
something with this you could create
that kind of attitude every single
freaking day of your life you could if
you train your mind and if you start
taking action and training your mind is
the key piece that we're going to talk
about so for those of you that have read
the high five habit one of the things
that I talk about a lot is every single
day find a naturally occurring
heart-shaped object in the world it
could be a stone it could be a leaf it
could be a cloud it could be a shape in
your coffee hey Chris if we've got
anything around here that looks like a
heart hand it to me and the reason why I
love telling you to start playing a game
with yourself where you start your day
going mind brain show me some heart oh
what is this come here dog treat oh my
God it's a dog treat look look at this
guys what shape is that that right there
is a
heart there we go check that out if you
say brain mind show me a heart today
guess what's going to happen that damn
dog biscuit it's going to show it's
going to you're going to be like there's
a heart you're going to look out at the
sky and you're going to see a heart
shape oh right there in the mountains
there's a heart shape in the mountains
in southern Vermont you're going to see
it in the clouds what you're doing when
you tell your mind what's important to
you is you're telling your mind and the
filter in your brain to change in real
time and allow into your
Consciousness what's important to you
and if you want to see hearts by God
those damn dog treats are going to start
looking like hearts everybody that's how
you train your mind it's freaking
incredible and if you want to see
evidence of this follow me on social
media if you follow me Mel Robbins on
social media you will see every day I am
reposting your stories of finding heart
shapes around the world now why is this
important well it's important because
it's a simple way to prove to you that
your mind changes in real time that if
you get serious about becoming more
positive and optimistic and encouraging
of yourself if you get serious about
saying this I don't want to see all the
reasons why I'm unhappy I don't want to
see uh everybody else in the world
that's launched a business or that's
lost lost weight and is healthy or that
has a really good uh marriage or
relationship and I don't want to see
that and and and have my mind process it
as evidence that it's never going to
happen for me I want my mind to
reprogram itself and see other people's
businesses and see other people getting
healthy and see other people in
relationships and I want my mind to say
yeah if they can do it I can do it
that's evidence if that person can get
healthy so can I if that person can find
somebody on hinge so can I if that
person can reconcile with their child so
can I other people can become evidence
that you can have it too right now your
mind is so up from your past that when
you see what other people have and you
don't have it you can't actually
translate it through a negative mind and
and see that that's evidence that you're
going to win you see it like oh somebody
already stole what I wanted that sucks
and so what I want to start to open your
mind to is that you have the power to
train your mind to filter the world
differently just like you woke up and
you saw the date today 22222 and your
brain saw that and was like whoa this is
a once- in a-lifetime day
everybody you are never going to have
another day that lines up like this
ever what are you going to do with this
day your mind already interpreted this
as
wow something cool could happen and if
you tell yourself something amazing is
going to happen
today something will because you're
going to be looking for it I swear to
God something will something will if you
want to see the good all around you you
got to tell your mind you want to see
the good and this just isn't a bunch of
hores everybody this isn't toxic
positivity there is a filter in your
brain called the reticular activating
system the reticular activating system I
call it the r R I like to think about it
like a giant hairnet on your head and
this Ras sits over your brain I'm
probably getting this wrong I'm not a
neuroscientist I could give a sh about
getting it right I just need you to know
the basics here so that you can apply it
to your life okay you don't need a PhD
to use the science that super smart
people have been working really hard on
in order to apply it to your life that's
what I'm here for in your life I'm here
to translate this stuff into to simple
believable and actionable things that
you can do to take all this super cool
stuff that people are researching and
apply it to your normal person's
everyday life to help you change from
the inside out and one of the coolest
things that you have at your disposal is
you have a whole system in your body
that you can train and change and one of
those things that you can train and
change that is is impacted by that real
that word you're hearing a lot of
neuroplasticity that just means that
things are able to twist and bend and
change and you're able to learn new
things for as long as you're alive as
long as you're breathing everybody you
got a chance to change the way that you
think as long as you are breathing you
got a chance to change from the inside
out how you experience your life as long
as you are still here watching me people
you got a chance to create a new
experience in your life and one of the
things that helps a lot is understanding
that right now all of the from
your past has jammed the filter in your
mind body and spirit the reticular
activating system and it is clouding
your ability to look at the world around
you and see hearts remember this dog
treat hearts look at that there's a
heart right there the Dallas Uber driver
oh so as somebody who has gotten into
countless Ubers and some small
percentage of them know who I am and
then of course they start asking
questions talk to me about chasing your
dreams and this quote that you have that
an aha moment does not necessarily lead
to an aha
life um yeah the Uber driver in Dallas
that's in this book um I get choked up
when I think about him uh an aha moment
why choked up I get choked up
because what happens for me every single
day is and you hear from people every
single day you've got millions and
millions of people that are inspired by
empowered by impacted by your content
there are people out there that use your
work as a
lifeline and it is humbling and what I
am really present to in the work that
I'm putting out in the stuff that I'm
sharing whether it's my failures or the
things that I'm using that are helping
me in my own
struggles is just how much people are
holding themselves back and how much
pain people feel because most folks know
what they dream about and what they
want and yet they're spending all of
their time and energy arguing against
what they want and so you can have all
these
epiphanies I hope that when somebody
listens to our conversation and watches
this that they have a massive aha moment
but it's not going to
mean if you don't take action and do
something about it the aha moment is the
door that opens but your new life does
not begin unless you step through the
door
and most people and that's what
was so kind
of you know the simple idea of
high-fiving yourself of encouraging
yourself of supporting yourself most
people when you have an aha moment and
the door to your new life opens
up instead of going I got this let's go
and high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go I don't know if I'm worth
it I don't know if right now is the
right time to do this I don't think I'm
good enough I failed so many times I
can't go through that door and that's
the problem I want to attack right now
that there is somewhere in your life
that you know what you want you can feel
it pulling you and you are actively
arguing against it you're bringing
yourself down you're beating yourself
out like people will cheer for you and
me they won't cheer for themselves I'm
the same way and so this Uber driver the
story that you're talking about I get
into the car and we start driving and
I'm on the phone as we're driving and
I'm having a conversation with somebody
about this daytime talk show that I
launched which was a dream with Sony
Pictures Television and then uh was
promptly fired after season one it was a
huge failure because we didn't make it
to season
two huge failure in real world terms
massive success when it comes to the
timeline of my life and so I'm talking
to this person about the talk show I
hang the phone and this Uber driver
comes alive he's like oh my gosh I can't
believe you're in my cab and I'm like
why and he says because I I want to talk
to you about something I think you can
help me and I'm like great how can I
help you and he says I have a dream of
being a
oscar-winning uh actor and creating
opportunities for other black and Latino
men to do the same in acting and I'm
like freaking fantastic what the are you
doing in Dallas right you know the guy's
25 and so I I I go you know the game is
in New York and La I mean sure you can
act you can write stuff you can be here
in Dallas but why are you not in La why
are you not in New York and he's like
you're right you're right you're right I
need to move to LA like why not and he
says I have $700 in my bank account I'm
like that's freaking fantastic you have
$700 in a car dude drop me off and get
driving what are you waiting for and so
we have this whole conversation and I
write about it in this book where I am
actively arguing for his dream and he is
actively arguing against his
dream and what is so sad is throughout
this conversation Tom he's like you're
right $700 could get me there you're
right I am only 25 you're right if I
keep thinking and thinking and thinking
and thinking about what I want to be
doing I'm not only going to drive in
circles my whole life is going to spin
in circles as I think about what I want
and I don't do about it and then you are
going to find yourself not at 25 but at
45 or 65 and you're going to be so
filled with regret that you never put a
put a bet on
yourself and so this conversation ends
with him declaring that he's going to go
to California and me giving him a bunch
of tools that I talk about in this book
and the point of the story is does he
move or not I don't
know the point of the story is it's so
easy to see what somebody else should do
it's so easy to cheer for somebody else
we all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us we do not
know how to do it for ourselves if
you're living in stress and you're
living in survival and that system is
switched on then everything will be a
threat everything will be a danger
everything will be a reason to rush to
be impatient to be frustrated to be
judgmental because that's that's the
Consciousness that's the emotion we're
living by so now you you have a a
problem with a coworker you have a
problem with your partner whatever it is
that you use as an example and you have
to give a presentation now now you
really have one of two choices either be
victimized by those conditions in your
life and you stay in that emotional
state and I'll say to you Jay why are
you that way well I'm this way because
of this person this circumstance the
person or circumstances controlling the
way I feel and the way I think anything
that controls the way I feel and the way
I think I'm victim to right okay or I
actually can be a Creator now okay so
when it's the hardest it matters the
most okay so there's going to be a story
a valid story that's going to go along
with those emotions that you're going to
have to give up that you can address at
another time from a different state if
you're altered in that state and you say
something you do something you write the
email you send the text you'll always
regret it you'll always say I should
have never said that I should have never
done that we got to learn that we're in
an altered state at that time so there
only one of two choices you either stay
there the whole day and tell everybody
that story or you say okay let me take a
moment remember that this is the
experiment called life okay let me
practice getting relaxed in my heart let
me slow the animal down let me practice
that take a few minutes now let me
breathe let me get my state back let me
change everything okay let me remember
who I am who I want to be when I open my
eyes and let me practice that again now
even if you had to do that 10 times in
one day I would say it was a day worth
living I would say it was a day worth
living and when we do walking
meditations uh in our our Retreats we're
doing walking meditations so you can
practice doing it with your eyes open
like if you're going to be relaxed in
your heart and awake in your brain and
you can do it with your eyes closed okay
let's take it out for a test drive let
me open my eyes let me pay a little bit
more attention to my my inner World let
me practice feeling this feeling let me
practice feeling this way and let my
brain do what it does let me get defined
let me change my physiology let me
change my state let me walk as the
healed person let me walk as the
Abundant person let me walk as if my
prayers are answered let me walk in the
state if I keep practicing that over and
over it's going to become a habit right
yeah so so we hit it as many ways as we
can we have at least seven or eight
different breaths that we do because we
see how they all work and
brain we have all kinds of meditations
we have Sitting meditations we have
standing and walking meditations we
laying down meditations because we want
you to be able to do it with your eyes
open with your eyes closed standing
walking any way you can so that you
don't default and return back to that
person now if you do default you didn't
fail that's a program you just went
unconscious and how many times do we
have to forget until we stop forgetting
and start remembering that's the moment
of change no one no one cares how many
times times you fell off the bicycle if
you ride the bicycle now you ride the
bike so it's it's the constant process
uh every single day and I think that
sometimes we look for evidence in our
life and it hasn't happened and I think
it's so important that we still show up
yeah yeah cuz that's the that's where
you're changing the most and when you
get to that point where you could care
less if it happens or not cuz you feel
so happy so grateful for who you are get
ready because your life is going to
begin to change in magical ways most of
us tell the story of our past in a
negative Sense on how it's held us back
um millions of times over our life as
opposed to the story of the future or
what we want to create or who we want to
become yeah listen again you tell that
story in the latest research on memory
says that memory is creative that in
fact 50% of that story you embellish
people make up that story let me tell
you why they make up that story because
they excuse themselves for the fact that
they haven't been able to change since
that event they'll have to make it sound
worse than it really was to make it
harder to grow and change so that they
can reaffirm their limited sense of
their inability to change so then that
story becomes more and more of a story
and it's less of the truth because you
got to work yourself up into a state
there were lions and tigers and there
was right you know they were helicopters
SN storms everybody was firing bullets
worst thing you could possibly imagine
and then you got to feel that emotion
right and you're look oh yeah it must
have been really bad now that's that's
your identity now that's your
identity the more you hold on to that
identity of the past the harder it is to
become who you want to be in the future
well here's here's to answer the other
part of your question when we started
talking how do you get that person out
of their past yeah well you got we need
a week it's not going to happen it
doesn't happen overnight no I want them
to come right up against their fear I
want them to come right up against their
doubt I want them to come up against the
point where they're going to give up and
quit and they're going to sit there and
nobody else is giving up and quitting
and they're going to go all in more and
they're going to start believing what
there's something on the other side of
that emotion they're going to believe
that there's something past the story of
their past because they're stretching
themselves out of the known and it takes
a tremendous amount of awareness
repetition information model building
sharing understanding experiencing to
finally have a person get to the point
where they just let go and when they do
the body's liberated from the past and
there's a release of energy and we now
know that there's a formula to teach
people how to do that in fact we're
getting so good at it that the first two
days day and a half sometimes one day in
certain groups of a week-long event is
about retiring that past finishing it
you know this is when the story ends
this is when they get over it now the
next five
days the person's ready to create a new
future and they're not going to have a
problem teaching their body what it
feels like to be in love with life to
feel like all their needs are met that
they're free they are going to fall in
love with it and they are going to begin
to Signal new genees are going to be
their change their brain circuitry their
brain chemistry their immune system
their gene expression that telling me
it's it's all going to happen they're
they're more of that future self and and
they're they're headed to a future now
here's the deal though you got to be
able to sustain that state when you
return back to your life that's the name
of the game you got to be able you got
to bring the game into your life now and
no person no circumstance no condition
in your life would cause you to feel the
old way again because the moment you
started feeling victimized the moment
you started feeling angry you just
returned to the old self you
disconnected from the energy of your
future and you're back to the energy of
your past the sense of being an outsider
is also something that I have
had throughout my
life and uh the sense
of not belonging
here
uh watching my
parents being
engaged in
continuous conflict
not because they were bad people they
were they did what they did and they
loved me as best they could and they did
what they
did as a reflection of their state of
consciousness at that time which was a
normal State of Consciousness egoic
State of
Consciousness but I sometimes felt how
did I get
here somehow didn't
there must have been a
mistake
um it's often
Outsiders
uh is being feeling an outsider on the
one hand is seems a terrible limitation
that you can't
participate as much on the other hand
it's a great opportunity
because some of the uh most creative
people uh in the world have have been
Outsiders they did not fit
in Misfits it's the English word
Misfits
um now that the friendships I had when I
was a
child and that's another interesting
thing I had
a friend one of my friends was had was
severely
physically
disabled and nobody else wanted to be
friends with him because of that and he
was probably my closest friend and the
other one was so weird that nobody
wanted to talk to
him uh but he became my friend so they
were Outsiders
too and uh
but the interesting fact here as you
know I couldn't believe it when they
told me that there are people here from
70 countries it seems almost unbeliev
but it's true I saw the
list 70
countries and you may find I'm sure you
will
find quite
often uh you you you can feel a bond or
you you have more in common
with many of the people who are
here then you have with your own people
in your own country at home who are not
going through any Spiritual
Awakening who are still totally
conditioned 100% conditioned by their
culture so you feel a connectedness here
with other humans that
transend culture and conditioning and
all this silly political stuff it
transcends that and this is a wonderful
thing so to some extent you can now
connect with people even if you don't
always see them physically you might
live I don't know whether you live in a
big city or small
village a small City small City small
City yeah yeah what city uh inbrook in
Austria oh yes yeah nice very nice and I
don't know how many people in insbrook
are
120,000 and how many of those are
Awakening we don't
know we don't know of course but this
helps I believe being here and feeling
you are not
alone you are
connected so this should be a help for
the rest you just have to accept that
this is how it is and no matter how hard
you try to fit
in on the normal level you probably
won't not you have to MH so I know this
there are many people here who feel that
and be happy with it but don't make it
into some kind of superiority because
the ego can always creep
in before you know it there's always a
back door and then the ego is back in so
you can you could go from from feeling
bad about being an outsider to suddenly
feeling okay I'm an outsider because I'm
superior and then so have to be careful
don't go there so um that's just how it
is if you you probably would not be here
if you had not been an out felt like an
outsider for many years so it worked
certain actions take place you do things
you
know they're
not the optimal things to do but you
can't help it it's
something acts through you um there
there seems to be some power there that
makes you do things that you know know
are not right or not good for you and
yet you can't stop it that seems to be
the case
um and that of course
um is often the case with people who are
with you it might be many different
different areas of your life but uh
um this is also the case with addictions
for example people who are addicted to a
certain substance or who are addicted to
eating too much or drinking um there's
something that over empowers them in you
that seems to
obscure the awareness or the awareness
is pushed to to recite and this thing
this this powerful thing does it
anyway and again my answer is a little
bit similar to
um what I say to the first questioner
tonight uh
the the power of
presence needs to grow in you so
that it is strong enough not to is not
willpower because willpower is not the
best way of dealing with these things
but it's what I'm talking about could
sometimes be confused with willpower but
willpower includes the um application of
a force to hold something down
let's say
um if your addiction is to um have a to
indulge in intoxicating beverages in
other words booze is the British word uh
then uh and you can feel it it's it
comes on there it comes you know the
bottles are there there they are and you
feel you have to go there and you have
to reach out and you have to pour
yourself a drink now
when you're not aware at all you don't
even know what you're doing you're so
unconscious that you you're already
holding the drink and you're drinking
then you at that point you you even know
that you're drinking uh the same with
food I've spoken to people who have had
addictions to food they often say they
wake up when they already they've
already eaten in the middle of the night
they've already unconsciously gone to
the fridge taken out the chocolate cake
and then they're already halfway through
the chocolate cake when suddenly like
what am I
doing but so awareness comes in at a
very late Point willpower would be to
hold an urge down that say I God they
have the pull or even what the example
you gave you want to turn on the TV and
you know it's not right because I I'm
not here for that and he actually told
us not to do
it
and I but I can't help it I have to go I
can't I can't no willower you would you
would say I'm going to hold this down
I'm not going to do
it and I can can feel the urge but
you're holding it
down um when you hold things
down often after a while the an
explosion happens
it's like a boiling
Kettle can't hold it for that long and
and then you have some kind of
rationalization in your mind why it
you'll do it anyway the mind will give
you a reason first you see the need the
to be a victim identity also
unfortunately is a form of
ego because any conceptual identity is a
form of ego and even though you seem to
be amply justified in in having a victim
identity because of the things that
other humans did to you you yourself are
finding you finding yourself in a kind
of
prison that created by your
mind so there's no denial of that bad
things happen to you yes now question is
how do you exit this mental
presence the first step is perhaps to
see
um that uh unconscious human
beings unconscious human beings in the
grip of their own conditioning their own
ego they have virtually no free
will when you are
unconscious you are controlled
by the the called Mind patterns that are
lodged in your
psyche you have you cannot really speak
of Free Will by somebody who with zero
awareness and yet their entire makeup is
uh conditioning from the
past so the famous sentence phrase used
by Jesus in connection with forgiveness
on the cross he said for forgive them
for they know not what they
do now these these two interesting these
points put together forgive them why
forgive them they know not what they do
in other words if he had spoken these
days using our
terminology he probably would have said
they're completely
unconscious because that's what it means
they know not what they do they are
completely
unconscious uh so when you see nobody
can act beyond their level of
Consciousness then you see that it's
almost like it becomes almost like the
evil that was perpetrated becomes almost
like a natural
phenomenon that is like you've been hit
by lightning or something
or lived in very
unpleasant climatic conditions that that
injured
you near
volcano my dad what what had problems
with anger huge outbursts of anger quite
frequently it was living like living
legs to a volcano that could erupt it
any
moment and he could not help it he was
it was impossible there was no
possibility of being
different and so these human
are run by unconscious conditioning
usually goes back to their childhood and
what happened
there I know why my father was angry I I
re I realized much later that it all
originated in his childhood the the
reasons why he was so angry and
also for a while also I felt a
resentment towards that and only when I
was able to awaken out of egoic
Consciousness I saw that the there's
nothing that he could have done
differently because there wasn't enough
awareness now when you see that then you
don't personalize or you don't create an
identity for other humans out of their
unconsciousness because in essence
that's not who they are the recognition
that there first recognition then step
one you recognize that no human can act
beyond their
conditioning in the absence of
awareness if there's awareness they can
transcend their conditioning and then
they begin to become conscious of their
own conditioned mentally emotional
dysfunctional mental emotional patterns
yes so they couldn't they can't help it
so that's that's already a useful step
in forgiveness but it you may not yet be
able to arrive at at full
forgiveness because of that another
before I continue with that does that
mean then a question may arise in your
mind does that mean then humans are not
really responsible for what they
do if if they are unconscious how are
they respon and does that mean then that
we shouldn't punish them for what they
do if they commit a
crime are they not
guilty that's an interesting
question
the the
unconsciousness that operates in human
even if you are able to forgive a human
and we come we'll go more fully into
that in a minute even if you're a to
forgive an human for their
transgressions or whatever they
did uh this does not mean and even
though the human is not responsible for
their
unconsciousness and
yet it is built into the structure of
human
life they still need to suffer the
consequences of their
unconsciousness usually happiness exists
as part of the play of opposites you
experience the happiness because
something makes you happy and then that
thing that made you happy either leaves
you or the very thing that made you
happy suddenly makes you
unhappy marriage for
[Music]
example or a
relationship before you start living
together you're happy when you start
living together you were
unhappy so what is if it's not happy
what are we talking about
the there's
a if
you let go of thinking and remain as the
awareness then there is in that that
awareness eminates a certain peace
alive
peace joy peace a
peaceful joyful sense of
aliveness inner peace maybe a better
word than happiness but one would have
to add to it it's an alive peace it's
not the piece of uh having deadened
yourself to
emotions or anything like that it's an
alive intensely alive piece you can
sense
it even if it's only just a glimps right
now surrender
thought and of
course right now if you're not thinking
about the problems of your alive there
are no problems in this moment there's
only a sense of beingness or
liveness and that is the connectedness
with
being and so you transcend the Opposites
between happiness and
unhappiness to reinvent yourself this
year check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there for me or
the people that I Mentor growth is a is
a key habit I call 60 minutes of
learning every day is is very very
powerful another great habit is the five
Great hours rule that I talk about in
the book